[Music]
there are things that we know and things
that we don't know but there are also
things we don't know that we don't know
that is why today we are going to look
at things that we don't know the answer
to even if you thought you did already
stay tuned to the end when we will show
you a mystery surrounding an everyday
object if this is your first time
visiting the things then what would be
really great is if you could give this
video a like and hit the subscribe
button today we are going to tell you
ten questions no one knows the answer to
why do cats purr if you are a cat owner
then you'll know just how much they can
purr and although we think that it's to
do with how happy they are we don't
actually know 100% why they perm it's
also been noticed that cats can
sometimes purr when they are in pain or
when they are injured cat expert
Elizabeth bond mug and Thaler has
suggested that the cats purr is part of
a natural healing mechanism but we also
don't know how cats purr they certainly
don't have an organ that makes them purr
the most popular theory says that cat's
vocal muscles vibrate while it's
breathing in and out causing a purring
sounds but no one knows for sure
what causes static electricity sometimes
we think we know how or why something
happens but then someone investigates it
and all the previous ideas turn out to
be wrong that is true of static
electricity if you don't know what that
is it's when two things rub together and
cause a small electric spark to be given
off for years scientists thought that
this was because friction removed the
electrons from the atoms in one of the
objects and transferred them to the
other object however in 2011 physicists
Bartos Grizz Bao ski of Northwestern
University USA published a research
paper that said that both positive and
negative electrons were transferred in
other words the research meant that what
we thought we knew about static
electricity was wrong why is ice
slippery with new discoveries they can
often take what we thought we once knew
and turn it on its head this can be true
when something seems obvious for
instance in 1859 the great scientist
Michael Faraday suggested that a thin
layer of liquid water covers ice even at
the coldest temperatures making it
slippery this sounded logical and
probably because Faraday was a genius
they went along with it but while his
claims were true they don't tell the
whole story
the pressure
our human body on ice is enough to
create that layer of liquid which is
what had been thought before so we still
don't entirely know why it is that ice
is slippery
how does turbulence work if you've ever
flown on an airplane then the chances
are you've experienced turbulence it's
pretty uncomfortable but it isn't
actually dangerous but that's just the
form of turbulence that we all know by
the name it's actually something that
happens all the time it happens when we
mix milk and coffee when a boat moves
through water and when smoke goes
through the air all turbulence is really
is disruption of a chaotic non
predictable nature but the thing is no
one actually knows how or why herb you
lence in its purest form exists the
problem about how to create a model of
turbulence has baffled scientists for
centuries and it has been described as
the most important unsolved question in
physics why do we have hypnic jerks have
you ever been falling asleep and then
felt like you were falling which causes
you to wake up suddenly the chances are
that you have that odd sensation is
called hypnic jerk and it's something
without any cause that we know of there
are plenty of ideas as to why we have
them scientists have argued that they
are caused by drinking caffeine or by
anxiety or by being busy during the
evening the only problem with those
ideas is that hypnotic jerks happen to
people who don't drink caffeine who live
stress-free lives and to relax in the
hours leading up to bedtime so we still
don't know why hypnic jerks happen how
does gravity work in science there are
things that are discovered and things
that are theorized if something is
discovered we know for sure that it's a
thing but if it's theorized technically
it might not exist now we know that
gravity exists but we don't actually
know why it exists it is one of the four
fundamental forces of nature alongside
strong interaction weak interaction and
electromagnetism but it's perhaps the
most mysterious of all of them
scientists aren't able to observe it in
a lab they have to work out how it works
by looking at how it affects planets and
solar systems it's believed that gravity
is caused by particles called gravitons
the only problem is that no one has
actually discovered them yet
why do we dream something that happens
to everyone every night is that we dream
scientists have found out when we dream
that they have
found out why if you want to know how
most people's dreams take place in the
deepest part of sleep known as rapid eye
movement or REM sleep however the jury
is still out about why we dream some
people believe that dreams are just the
brain common itself down but other
people believe that dreams help to
process information their theory is that
dreaming helps the brain sort out what
it needs to keep and what it needs to
throw away others say dreams are the
subconscious revealing its fears and
desires but no one knows for sure what
is the universe made up we know what
makes up 5% of the universe all those
things are made from atoms the tiny
particles that combine to make elements
which make up things but strangely
scientists aren't so sure about the
remaining 95% they have some idea about
what some of it is but not all of it
research indicates that a large chunk of
that 95% is something called dark matter
and another part is dark energy dark
energy is the thing that means that our
universe is continually expanding while
dark matter is the stuff that is
impervious to light we think as it is
even the best scientists in the world
don't know what they're made of
not yet anyway how did life begin in
1953 the scientists Stanley Miller and
Harold Urey carried out an experiment
that showed that organic living material
could in the right conditions come from
inorganic inanimate material the two men
argued that back when the earth was
first formed the atmosphere of our
planet was a lot like this this idea was
known as the primordial soup theory and
it was well accepted because the
experiment was convincing however what
we don't know is what exactly triggered
the creation of life on Earth some
scientists argue that it happened
naturally with the process started by
lightning strikes but the rival argument
is that it was actually triggered by a
series of meteor strikes but whatever
happens we are here now why do we still
use the QWERTY keyboard here's something
that you probably see every day a
computer keyboard now as you may already
know it's the same layout as a
typewriter keyboard now when typewriters
were first invented in the 19th century
they were slow letters had to be spaced
apart from each other so the keys
wouldn't Jam however that is no longer
relevant to computers and touchscreens
so why do we use the QWERTY layout there
isn't really a
it's just that that's how most keyboards
are by the way did you know that in
parts of the French speaking world the
top line of the keyboard is a de rty IOU
P anyway we'd like to know what
questions that no one knows the answer
to have we missed out tell us in the
comments and that's it for our 10
questions no one knows the answer to if
you liked it then check out 10 insane
life hacks you should dare to try thanks
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]